good evening everyone
and
we have a number of people checking in
from India welcome
this is just under two minutes
foreign
this is a cool session because we'll
hear from three of The Faculty members
from IMT ghaziabad
so
not not usual that we get three faculty
members
in one of our webinars but we did
uh
we have their comments here
check one last thing here for just a
second
[Music]
oh
foreign
out there
okay
all right
so
recording is in processed great
and I want to welcome everyone to our
webinar about a program from The
Institute of Management technology
certification in digital marketing
IMT has chosen simply learn to be the
delivery partner for this program and
part of the program is also powered by
meta so
let's get started
now uh I'll be talking yeah
like the uh professors will be talking
about digital marketing as a
industry segment and a career field
then I'll be talking about what this
program offers and how it gets your job
ready
and we'll cover the enrollment steps for
those of you who are interested in
enrolling and we'll also reveal a bonus
offer for you from being here at this
webinar tonight
and if you have questions for us along
the way please put them in the Q a
if you happen to be watching on YouTube
streaming
put those into the chat box but I'll be
asking some polls as well if you're in
Zoom you'll be seeing
um
a poll widget that will let you answer
those questions but if you're on
streaming you can put ABCD for answers
into your chat as well so
let me let you know who is
with us today
we have
uh Professor Sandeep
Hub day
Professor Bindu Gupta and professor
subhajit sengupta
um they joined us at a previous session
of this webinar and I have their
comments here so I'm going to go
straight
to the
first Professor Sunday
thanks to Art so and welcome everybody
to this webinar so uh basically all of
us know that the economy overall is
moving towards digital transformation
and we are using digital for every
aspect of sales and marketing so like
either we customer acquisition creating
brand awareness
understanding what the customer want
even the relationship management
and it you see more and more the
traditional media like the newspapers TV
are getting replaced by social media and
even the buyer or consumers
they prefer
or give much more importance to
electronic order mouth compared to what
the brands want to communicate through
their advertisement or traditional
advertisement so if you want to buy any
restaurant or who want to buy a go to
any Resort or buy any expensive
Electronics the first thing we do is to
basically go to and view the reviews in
different places so that is also
excellent source of information about
understanding what the customer wants
from the brand and as a result
more and more organizations are becoming
digital and if you see like even in
India most of the retail stores like who
are traditional brick and mortar they
are nowadays now not so much successful
is the era Omni Channel retailing the
retail store which has both online and
offline they are more successful so
with this uh we'll speak about it much
more in the details when you join this
basically program so now we'll hand over
to for the next slide
okay and I'd like Professor tsubishi to
um
talk about this in the in the slide
after
yeah uh thanks Robert uh I welcome
everybody I hope my voice is clear and
uh it's a loud and clear to everybody
so uh uh let's talk about the different
career options that you have as a
digital Market when you acquire digital
marketing skills first of all let me
tell you this digital marketing world is
very Dynamic okay so you need to keep
upgrading yourself you need to keep
learning okay and these learnings are
majorly many a times by trial and error
also okay so let's talk about a digital
marketer this is the uh job aspect of a
digital marketing manager okay so
digital marketing manager as a whole
talks about and takes care of the
digital well-being how the company is
performing digitally you know what are
the contents it's performing how it's
doing its social media's campaign
strategies and everything is the overall
digit uh job of the digital marketing
manager to keep a track of everything of
each part of the digital aspects okay
now one by one you will be having you
can also be an email marketing manager
or a specialist in the email marketing
many times you might have seen you know
uh there are certain emails that reach
out to you for feedback back emails
reach out to you for you know coupons or
which we call a sales promotional
activities and many times we ended end
up buying or opening emails and even
clicking uh from the emails and end up
into the product page so how are these
emails being triggered you know what
makes you uh what makes the conversion
happens which uh keywords actually are
working so that keeps a man that's the
work of a email marketing manager
content marketing manager as you know
it's the era of 2023 so we talk about
content is the king so everything you do
digitally if you're
um
it is not up to the date uh nobody will
be you know uh like to until and unless
your content is up to the date providing
the information that uses such uh your
content uh you know uh your uh products
will not be selling you would be not at
the top of the mind of the consumers
that is one of the major objectives
right so content marketing manager is uh
uh responsible for say the content being
created be it Instagram uh be the link
post that being created by the company
the emails that have been created okay
that are being you know circulated or
broadcasted you can say so with all the
different types of Beats and YouTube
video that is uh you know YouTube video
ad that is being created for conversion
so all these are a part of content
marketing manager or the blog posts the
normal blog post or even the uh the
content of the website these are all
part of the content marketing manager
now talk about the social social media
strategist okay many a days
these days companies are adopting or you
know uh uh you can say companies are
providing a special role as a social
media uh strategist or social media
manager to you so these uh actually you
know these uh uh social media the
objective of social media manager is to
keep a track of you know uh all the
happenings of the social media social
media is quite uh you know trending and
it's quite dynamic in nature so today uh
one thing which is which went viral
tomorrow it's not viral right so the
virality of the content is very much
crucial so it should reach out to the
right person at the right point of time
when the person is searching for or the
person has an intent towards the product
or the services right so social media
manager has to take keep a track of
where are the customers where are the
customers searching for what kind of
content they are consuming how to
strategize that these are all part of
the social media manager now talk about
the digital advertising manager so uh
you would be hearing about or you would
be seeing these days you must have
observed you know there are multiple ads
coming on YouTube uh at least two ads
even before a video starts so how are
these ads being created there is an
option within the ad that drives you
towards you know uh the web page or the
product page so how are these being done
so these are all examples of digital
advertising manager pay-per-click
marketing planner so many times you are
also you know clicking or searching for
the ad and you are paying for the ad
right so
um sorry you are not paying so when many
times you're clicking for the ad and uh
the website that you land up is paying
to Google or the search engine
um that it is operating with so many
times uh that's how is the budget being
uh you know uh
you can talk about the objective of a
pay-per-click marketing management
planner is to how is to allocate the
budget along different search engine
platforms how it is working which
keywords to Target uh where are the
customers searching for what are the
keywords customers are searching for all
these are the part of pay-per-click
marketing planner e-commerce manager
manages how the e-commerce websites are
looking for how is you know the
visibility of the products how is the
you know accessibility of different uh
products available to the e-commerce
platform all these are taken care of by
e-commerce manager whereas website
managers also takes care of the certain
aspects uh like how's the website
looking what are the you know title tag
meta tags how are they working how are
they functioning and they have to be
kept on changing right it's not that
once you are done and done so that's
that has to be you know very dynamic in
nature so website manager takes the
takes care of the you know overall flow
of the website how it is you know the
website should run as fast as possible
should not take much of the time so the
loading time all these are taken into
consideration by the website manager and
lastly the SEO analyst so uh many these
days almost majority of the companies
recruit an SEO Specialist or a SEO
analyst who make sure that the website
ranks higher for the you know uh for the
keyword or for the product or the
services that the company is offering so
that's that is an exam that is a duty of
the SEO analyst to make sure that the
website ranks higher and higher so
everybody you you might have remembered
you know uh nobody remembers the web uh
the person who comes second so it's
always the you know the websites are on
a race you know to become the first and
you have experience that you know you
generally visit the first page of uh the
search engine result page right you then
you are rarely looking for uh or
clicking on the second page so
definitely it's an objective of the
website to rank Higher and Higher and
that's taken care by the SEO analysts
okay moving on next uh can we have the
next slide please yeah
so these are some of the skills uh you
know that need to be kept it up uh kept
uh that you need to learn and you need
to keep yourself updated with for
example SEO optimization so what does an
SEO specialist does is he optimizes the
search engine results accordingly he
makes certain changes there are certain
you know tricks and techniques that has
to be incorporated in your website so
that your website ranks higher and
higher in for a particular keyword okay
so for a particular keyword or for a
particular product on the services which
the company is meant for uh content
marketing so definitely how are you
creating content okay how are you
managing the content how are you know
what is the strategy behind it which
kind of content people like what are the
keywords what are the hashtags you're
using for that all these has to be taken
care of web analytics okay
now nothing you cannot understand uh
until and unless it is Data driven okay
your decision has to be made based on
certain data right so data based
decision making is takes you for a
longer run right so definitely web
analytics helps you in understanding how
are your consumers performing right so
what are the which kind of consumers are
visiting your website which kind of
customers are bouncing back from your
website which kind of customers are
visiting your social media web page so
all these are taken into consideration
into web analytics and how can we target
them so these are all a part of your web
analytics website management and
optimization you can talk about you know
uh different ways in order to optimize
the website right so as soon as it is it
is it is you know it is a general rule
of thumb that the website should load
within two seconds okay now we do not uh
you can say we do not uh like to wait
right uh SO waiting time is uh very much
uh boring to everybody of us right so
website management and optimization is
one of the key aspects of that you know
so how how can we make the codes and how
can you know uh the website be managed
in such a way uh that it it loads faster
and faster and also it matches to the uh
you know uh for to the uh say the um
information that the users are searching
for so that has to be taken care of as a
part of website manager and optimization
social media strategies so what kind of
when where how to post is a part of
social media strategy so uh there are
certain platforms that are being created
you know certain calendars social media
posting calendars that are being created
which takes into consideration of how
the website uh how the social media
social media posts are going live
um
I can't see the screen is there yeah
okay now let's talk about the email
marketing yeah so email marketing talks
about you know uh how what are the kinds
of emails that are uh being uh
broadcasted to its customers right so
for example whenever you uh register for
a company buy an app or whatever there
is a different kind of email that
reaches to you whenever you left left
your product into the cart and did not
check out a different kind of email
comes to you uh whenever you bought a
product and you uh there then a review
email comes to you so there are
different kinds of email that are being
uh you know curated for different kind
of situation and how these contents are
being created these are all parts of
email marketing strategy pay-per-click
strategy so how much uh to spend
in order to you know uh uh so how much
to spend in order to uh uh so for
example suppose pay-per-click strategy
is uh what is the strategy to be adopted
in terms of uh this uh say the digital
ads or the search ads that are coming
into the picture Okay so that is an uh
part of pay-per-click strategy ad
testing which kind of ads people are
clicking which kind of extensions are
working so these are all part of AD
exchange ad testing and extensions
keyword organization and match types
different kinds of keywords multiple
websites are using multiple keywords
okay so how can you optimize your
business or your website according to
the keywords campaign and AD group
organization so how can you manage
different ads okay so one company would
be running multiple ads at a certain
period of time or multiple campaign so
how can you manage all that uh say via
using Google ads uh for example is is a
part of campaign and AD group
organization so I hope uh I'm able to
you know uh provide you a glimpse of
what a digital marketing roles and what
are the you know uh key skills that you
will be learning however there's a there
were a lot more we'll be discussing on
the floor over to you steward
okay and
we'll be hearing
from our third Professor just shortly
but first off
let's go back to our
presentation
I'm going to ask a poll of the audience
what uh has stopped you from pursuing a
certification of this type up till now
obviously you're all here because you're
interested in the field
we're curious to know why you haven't
taken this step so far as because you
can't find a comprehensive curriculum
that covers all the things that
subject talked about uh is it because
you don't have confidence you'd have
practical experience and show off your
new skills
is it because learning style has been
uh different from what you learn best
from or is it because you can't find
I'm in your work schedule
I'll leave this open for another just
another five seconds
three
two
one
and
I will share the result here
and the leading answer uh today's
audience is
spending time in your work schedule
it's always a concern for working
professionals
and then the other three are fairly
evenly
um
equals importance
so let me move on
share with you how this program works
this is the digital marketing program
from I I IMT ghaziabad Institute of
Management technology
and
as I mentioned it's delivered by simply
learn it's powered by meta in part and
it is a five month program we say you
should probably set aside five to ten
hours a week for this program
um yeah the comprehensive curriculum
I'll be talking a little bit more about
that in a minute
to Industry aligned based on the
experience that intg has
with working with companies and
understanding what it is they're looking
to hire in their new digital marketing
hires
um so the curriculum matches to that
the platform provides you the ability to
do integrated case studies and projects
on the same platform that you're taking
the live virtual classes on live virtual
classes of course allow you to interact
with your instructor
answer their questions ask them
questions directly talk to your
batchmates
and gives you that live experience that
you can't get from a self
-paced video program
and finally it's designed to be flexible
so that other than the class times for
the live sessions everything else you do
can be done on your own time anytime 24
7.
and
fit those 10 hours a week into any slot
that you have available in your personal
schedule
I will also be talking about what you
receive at the end of the program so you
receive your professional certificate
a digital marketing from IMT ghaziabad
they certify and we'll certify to anyone
that you have completed the program
successfully and gained the skills
taught you in the program uh you gained
those skills through Hands-On case
studies you do the Capstone project at
the end of the program
to demonstrate all of your skills and
provide you with a practical work
experience example
uh you get master classes from industry
leaders along the way as well as exam
voucher for The Meta certified digital
marketing associate program
and you can you can achieve associate
alumni status with IMT ghaziabad
so I'm going to ask Professor Bindu
to share her comments about the
Institute so go back here
uh good evening everyone welcome to this
webinar uh so it's about IMT is a very
early institute around more than 40
years old Institute and we are among the
top in student India
we have many accolades with us like we
have a a specific meditation this is
international accreditation and also
apart from that we also have a national
accreditation also
and I I think and we and we have I think
uh more than thousand uh alumni who are
working in the top positions in India
and abroad okay
and also our marketing program is a flag
Flagship program and we have a faculty
more than uh uh I think I think more
than 10 faculty in a marketing area
around I think 15 and also most of the
faculty cover very strong experience uh
of Academia plus also from industry and
really I'm very proud to be the part of
this institute and and and I think all
of you will enjoy being a part of this
digital marketing program where our
faculty will deliver the uh the content
of this program and also uh it will be a
very good Mentor for you uh in your uh
career Journey also so this is uh all
about IMT if you have some more
questions then we will take up in the uh
in the question answer sessions thank
you thank you yeah thank you Professor
Bindu
all right
I've mentioned a couple of times meta as
well and meta provides Master sessions
and ask me anything sessions
gives you access to the certification
exam voucher so that you can take their
exam
as part of this course included in the
fee
and this gives you a second
Avenue for independent certification of
your digital marketing skills this is a
valuable part of the program we're very
proud that meta chooses to work with us
in this
so this program requires that you have a
bachelor's degree be in any discipline
it does not have to be in marketing or
business management
or in digital technology
it is desirable you have work experience
in digital marketing but this is not
required
um
and you again desirable that you have at
least two years of work experience of
any type in the formal working world
but again this is not a hard and fast
requirement so the main thing is to have
your bachelor's degree and have a
strong interest in aptitude for digital
marketing
so
let me ask another poll question of the
audience
this poll question is how much
experience do you have in the Working
World
are you currently studying for your
undergrad degree are you
working
The Professional
how many years of experience
and I'll leave this open just for
another five seconds it's a very
straightforward question three
two one
poll share results
so we have
a bit more than a third of our audience
are people who are still in school
and then we have a kind of a split
between people who are fairly new in
working
in people who have more than five years
of experience
the
thank you for that
move on
how this program prepares you this is
important to understand the curriculum
because the curriculum is built up with
a number of core courses and then a
number of electives that you can choose
to take uh based on your particular
desire and experience so the electives
are included in the cost of the program
and you can choose to take them at your
your discretion
but the forecast
curriculum starts with the program
induction session which teaches you how
to use the
learning management system platform it
gives you an overview of your curriculum
and all the options how to get enrolled
in each course what to do to prove that
you've completed the course
successfully and then how to unlock both
a certificate for the course you just
pleaded completed and then unlock
enrollment to the next course in
sequence and this goes into step-by-step
fashion because you want to make sure
that you are equipped to succeed in each
course with the preparation from the one
before so
after the induction your first formal
courses introduction to digital
marketing the overview of course it
gives you kind of a rounded uh idea of
what the field entails
then the
skill of search engine optimization
which is extremely important for every
aspect of digital marketing because
search engines drive so much of it
pay-per-click advertising
then you move into social media
marketing
web analytics which is extremely
important to understand for the
performance of your
digital marketing programs and how
changes to those programs can affect
their Performance Marketing analytics
take Ties That more directly into
performance specific to marketing and
then finally a digital marketing
Capstone project the Capstone project
you're going to choose a challenge
that's aligned from
Street requirements
you get to pick a problem to solve and
you'll build your own solution to them
about that more in a minute
um
are the electives that you can choose
from include brand management mobile
marketing uh email marketing content
marketing
um website conversion rate optimization
to improve the uh performance ultimate
results that you get for your website
The Meta Master session and digital
leaders master classes where you'll be
hearing from people who work in digital
marketing and uh in the industry that
come in from outside and talk to you
now we talk about
the tools and platforms you will use
you'll learn these by doing projects
with them so you'll be called on to use
these in your course projects
for each course as well as in the
Capstone project at the end
means for all the projects that are all
the tools that you've used in your
projects you'll have examples in your
portfolio to be able to show off
demonstrate your skill in that area so
you won't just be putting these tools on
your resume as buzzwords you'll be able
to prove that you have used and
understand how to use each of them
this is a really valuable part of the
Practical experience that
and again we go back to the Capstone
project because it's really extremely
important to have that
um
it's about a three to four week module
of the program and it
takes you through solving that problem
on your own you meet with your
instructor weekly to review your
progress they'll take you through an
example and then you'll get to work on
your own independent project and and you
get to choose the area from the
different choices
and you build it all yourself and
that becomes part of the portfolio you
take with you from the program
to be able to show off your actual
digital marketing skills this is a part
of the Practical experience aspect of
this program as well
the learning environment gives you the
ability to manage your curriculum
to take the live virtual classes
to do tests projects uh assessments Labs
all on the same platform
you can do your Capstone project on the
platform
and it tracks your progress through the
uh
program so that if you happen to be
falling behind the system will prompt
you to catch up and it will keep track
of your progress with certificates for
each of the courses you complete
and your eligibility for the the
voucher for meta or final certificate
for the court for the whole program
along the way you get support tools that
include a 24x7 help desk
as well as a community Forum that lets
you
ask for advice and support from your
peers and from
faculty of the programs
you're working on your project at three
o'clock in the morning and you to doubt
or a blocker you'll be able to turn to
somebody for help
so Professor Sandeep Professor Bindu and
Professor subijit are the
three main program
leaders and advisors for the uh program
and you've met them briefly
um but
they are the ones who designed this
program and
curriculum
they'll deliver it and a large part of
the teaching themselves and we're
extremely proud to be associated with
supplement are very proud to be
Associated I think they chose us to
deliver this program on our platform
so
we talk about learner outcomes here's a
couple of examples from RN and archid
who
went through the program and are very
happy with the results they achieved so
uh iron got a salary hike of 40 percent
from finishing the course so that's a
great practical outcome
and um
one of the things that arjit said was
that that he was able to fit this into
his
schedule as a working professional
easily
these are both examples of
people who have taken the program and
gotten very successful results from it
we hope that you'll be able to
contribute stories of your own this
one of the factors in the program that
simply learn provides is the career
service the job assist program
this is specific to Learners in India
unfortunately I know we have for example
learner tuned in from Dubai today
um
fortunately we don't offer it there but
we if you are an India learner you will
be eligible for these Services which
extend for six months after you earn the
imtg certificate
um personally have access to webinars
and career events that simple inputs on
weekly user-free and you have lifelong
access to those you also have your
project portfolio of the work you've
done up to and including your Capstone
project which is the Practical
experience you take with you to show off
in your job search to potential future
employers during your interviewing
process and then the job assist services
with IIM jobs is a formal a set of job
assist services that include access to
the job portal which gives you not only
access to the different jobs employers
that are on the portal but also gives
you a way to apply to those jobs uh
discreetly without
exposing your job search on a public
board like uh indeed or Glassdoor
um then there's the
resume rewrite service
extremely valuable in the case
in age because
resumes don't go to human beings until
after they've gone through an automated
tracking system
and an AI bot and the AI bot will filter
you in or out of the job search based on
how it matches your skills and your
experience
to the job description
so having a resume that's written so the
AI bot can understand what your skills
and experience are and match them up
filter you into the process
is an important skill but you still have
to realize your resume will show up on
somebody's desk or on their screen after
that so it still has to be appealing to
the human eye
and this reason it's important to work
with professional resume writer who can
balance the two objectives of
compatibility with the AI bot and human
appeal
um so this is a really valuable part of
the service the other part the
one-on-one interview is also extremely
valuable because in the job search
you'll be going through multiple rounds
of interviews which can range from the
phone screen by the HR department or
recruiter to the technical skills
interviews with your potential new peers
and supervisor you need to know that you
can do work uh to the management
compatibility interviews that talk about
your soft skills
or ability to be a good teammate your
work ethic and your fit with the
corporate culture so each of these
interviews has a different tone flavor
and objective and you have the
opportunity to practice each of these to
be putting your best foot forward
this is a great part of the service
again these Services extend for six
months after you get your certificate
and you can use them to whatever extent
you want
it's much or as little as you want they
are not a job placement or guarantee
service but they are a great set of
tools for helping you find that next job
I mentioned the webinars and simple
learn runs these weekly to provide
Career Education and overviews of
Industry segments so there will be
digital marketing
segment overviews of what the trends are
for the coming year in digital marketing
that type of as well as
skills for job search like how to get
the best result for job boards or how to
develop your soft skills and
prove your career tools for your
personal career advancement or how to
look at the new technical areas new
technologies that are emerging so these
are valuable career lifelong education
tools and again free and available to
you and then we talk about the
case studies and projects and these are
some examples of kinds of things that
you might do for example as a case study
during course or a Capstone project
you might
look at Social Media communication for a
charitable organization for example you
might look at uh
the strategy that Domino's used
your Capstone projects comes from one of
four domains it'll be travel banking
Financial Services uh consumer goods are
hospitality
and pick a challenge from one of those
areas
and do more than one if you wish but uh
people
aren't quite that ambitious but if you
are you have that option so let me move
on to the find my mouse here we go
uh another poll question
and based on everything that the
professor shared with you and that I've
talked about today are you interested
in enrolling in this boot camp
I'll leave this open for just another
five seconds
or three
two one
oh
85 percent of our audience today is
interested
in
enrolling in the program so I'm going to
share with you how to do that
on
enrollment steps are extremely
straightforward
they involve sending an email to ask us
at simplylearn.net
I'm going to put that into the chat so
that you have that available don't have
to transcribe it
um copy
and
just a moment while I put that into the
chat for you
there it is
and in the chat you'll find the email
address there
when you send a contact us there our
learning consultant will contact you in
return and get your information you need
to be able to provide documentation of
your bachelor's degree
any work experience that you want to
claim and then there will be questions
and assessment of your digital marketing
understanding and aptitude and then
based on that we will
send you an admission offer if you pass
the review
you can start so
the next induction session happens
two days on the 29th of March
that is for the classes that start 20
May
um can't be in the 29 March session
there will be other inductions before
that 20 Mark 20 may start a date so uh
you wanted to get in quickly we talked
about limited seats
there's a reason why we talk about
limited seats even though this is
completely digital program
the virtual classes
have the same characteristics as if you
were in a live physical class that means
the instructor needs to be able to work
with each student and devote enough time
and attention to them so we limit the
batch sizes
and uh
need to get your application in early so
that you can get into the next batch
the program fees as you can see here are
inclusive of tax one lock 1999
and the financing can be as low as 3386
rupee per month
if you are in a different country you'll
probably see from our website I'll share
that later
what the
pricing is in your local region but this
is the pricing for India and the bonus
we talked about I mentioned the
beginning of the webinar is a 15
discount for attending this webinar so
if you contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to inquire about getting
enrolled remember to mention
at this webinar get a 15 discount
and
So based on that for those 85 percent of
you who said you were interested I'm
going to ask another quick question
which is
uh how soon would you want to start
do you want to get into that 20 May
cohort or maybe June July
or are you looking further down the road
and I'll just leave this open for
another 10 seconds
all right five four three two one
so
uh almost 60 percent of our audience are
interested in getting into the May
cohort or the one right after that the
rest of you I encourage you as well to
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
so that we can keep in touch with you if
you are advised of future cohorts and
also answer any questions
so
this point speaking of questions I'm
going to go to the questions and answers
and again I'll be looking mainly in the
Q a part of
the
uh
excuse me q a part of the
Zoom feature here and I will take a
quick scan of the chat before we finish
but
Anonymous attendee when will you give me
a certificate we
we do you will be able to request a
proof of attendance for tonight's
session in just a moment
um
the certificate for the actual digital
marketing
skills happens after you take the
program
um
what is the best SEO or PPC in the AI
world
that's an interesting question
um
and the question it's not I'm not clear
uh Priya if you're talking about
um
the best AI tool to use for SEO
uh PPC
um Google certainly has its own AI tools
that are built into
their offerings their PPC offerings
so they have things that will
uh suggest keywords for you uh just uh
pricing bidding
there's those tools but
you'll learn more about the these uh
available tools
in the SEO and the PPC modules in the
program
uh RNs is a degree needed to learn
digital marketing so a degree
in general
you can learn digital marketing and
practice digital marketing without a
degree but for this program you do need
to have a degree
one of the requirements that IMT
ghaziabad has instituted and part of
that is
they're looking
as that as an objective proof that you
can take on a
long-term program and complete it
successfully so uh in this case yes you
do need to have a bachelor's degree
um
is there any Emi system available
and
are we talking about uh electronic
payments uh
clarify that uh sorry this is a
with this program you are able to
Finance it
through a low interest financing zero
interest funding as a matter of fact on
a monthly basis so
um
some very cool please conduct some free
courses for digital marketing
um I will mention that simply learn
on its website has a section called
skill up
you will be able to go through there and
see some of the free courses that we do
offer if you complete the course on our
certificate there's a fee for getting
the certificate of the courses
themselves are free however they're all
self-study videos and so you don't get
the benefit of
contact with the faculty of imtg you
don't get the contact with
meta personnel
don't get the industry expert
contact you don't get the Hands-On case
studies and Labs or the Capstone project
the we do offer free resources and
sometimes those free resources are great
Preparatory work before you take a paid
course
um
you can check those out again at the
simplylearn.com website
but uh
again they they don't compare to what
this program offers
an anonymous attendee asks who digital
marketing go away with the advancements
of AI answered that is
no there's still somebody
will be required to match
the requirements of the organization and
what you're selling to
the tools of AI that are being used to
help you sell it so
you can't simply
won't simply be able to type into chat
GPT please sell my product
um
it can offer you ideas that can offer
you maybe uh
um drafts of content writing that you'll
then have to to edit to make it sound
like it came from a human being
um
a lot of great AI tools out there
but again human beings have to guide
them so understanding
digital marketing and having these
skills is going to be extremely
important so that you can be the master
of the AI tools rather than the other
way around
how long is the class this session is
one hour but the uh the program itself
is five months
what are the timings for the courses in
India you want to ask that of the
learning consultant some of them will be
on weekends some of them will be
evenings
and they can give you the specific
timings as well but there there will be
timed conveniently for an audience in
India which means that if you're in a
different country you'll have to adjust
the time a little bit it'll be uh
the morning class in India it'll be a
very early morning class if you're in
Dubai so
um
equal monthly installments yes Emi
and that's exactly what we showed on
that slide a little over three thousand
rupee per month equal monthly
installments
um paid off over time
so that's
that's uh
already been covered
okay send me uh you have a question
about some of the other resources we
offer and this is not the right uh form
for that but if you do contact ask us at
simplylearn.net they will be very happy
to cover that with you
um and answer those questions in more
detail so I I recommend you do that
so that you can
ask specific questions and get answers
with that
that you have a very valid set of
questions here so
uh
uh certificate at the end of the webinar
we'll cover that in just a moment
so before I move on to that
please let me
quickly check our chat and see if
there's anything I have missed
a lot of messages that I can see in the
chat that you can't
uh through
you real quick
please bear with me for a moment
all right
and
pretty sure that you've all been very
diligent about putting the questions
into the Q a so I'm not seeing
uh any
any questions
that we haven't covered
all right
so with that I'm going to move on to the
last part of our
webinar
I want to ask a question here you can
request a certificate for attending
tonight's session
if you would like that
um
answer yes
also answer yes if you want us to reach
out to you keep in touch with you ask
answer your questions for you help you
get enrolled so
if you want a certificate for tonight's
webinar or if you want
um
help with getting enrolled please answer
yes to this question I'll leave this
open for another five
four three
two one
and
it's just about 50 50. so
for those of you who answered yes we
will be contacting you uh both with your
proof of attendance for tonight's
webinar as well as uh helping you with
any questions you have and getting
enrolled
and with that
I want to apologize for my sniffles
I want to point out that this QR code
will take you to the
webinar page and I'm going to put this
just obscured the QR code but I'm going
to put it to the URL into the
chat just now so
I'll be able to find that there as well
you don't want to snap the picture
you can either use the QR code or the
URL that I just put into the chat and
that will take you to the program page
or the int ghaziabad digital marketing
program
and otherwise contact us and ask us at
simplylearn.net and I put that in the
chat as well so you'll be able to find
that
and I want to thank everyone for taking
their time this evening to be with us
we appreciate your interest and we
really hope that we can welcome you into
the Learning Community with simply learn
and IMT ghaziabad so again thank you for
being here and that concludes
the webinar for this evening
foreign